[Music]
you know there's a great russian saying
that says man thinks and god laughs
like as a true operator i think about
this a lot if you actually recognize
how much is out of your control
the weight of your decisions
dramatically decreases
people fear changing their mind out of
judgment how do you pull out of that
decision like if you're stop
worrying about other people's opinions
so many of you
have become non-change reminders because
you're worried about other people's
opinions
you must deconstruct this because
changing your mind
is the ultimate strength
gary changed his mind on wine content
gary changed his mind on zoom calls on
numerous hires
on media non-fitness non-daily vlogging
on using airpods
my career on uber on cam laptops
linkedin
gary changes his mind every day hey guys
i'm katie
i'm gary's influencer partnerships
manager in this film
we're trying something different we
interviewed a variety of people in
gary's world from the time when he sold
baseball cards to the present
what we'll learn here is how changing
direction played such a big role in
gary's success and how it affected
people around him
first we'll take it to the early days of
gary's personal brand in 2016
with sid my first role on the team was
an intern i
was a summer intern on team garyvee in
2015
and i was really observing everything
around
everything that gary was making
decisions with like how he was acting
how he was
communicating with his employees and
everything so one of the
really big moments for me was when
i realized that he was always all in and
at the same time he was always
ready to say that he was wrong and
wanted to really pivot
and that's why i asked him this question
on the askgaryvee show
i've seen you go all in when you're like
doing something but then i we also as a
team have seen that you
step back and see things in a wider
perspective and then you change
direction
so how do you decide when it's like
moment to just step back and
reconsider this question is the same
question of like
you know like how do you know when to
hit the high note like
when do you know it's game time and
you've got to shoot and stop passing the
ball
his summary of the answer was really
that it's a very instinctive thing and
it's literally something that you're
born with and it's not something you can
teach someone so
in his words it's literally something
that you're born with
and that's how you just react to
instincts and that's why some people are
successful some people
aren't because even though you're you're
reacting to these instincts and this is
more of my understanding of his version
even though you're reacting to instincts
a lot of people that are
not comfortable or insecure enough to
like not
to be wrong and that's where like they
start questioning their instincts
and that's where things really change
for some of the people i fail every day
like the amount of things that i make
decisions on that don't work out
are every day i think one of the great
ways to tell the difference between a
winning entrepreneur
and a losing entrepreneur is how much
they enjoy losing
what sid observed is that gary's ability
to change
comes from an instinct he was born with
but can this be learned
my name is andy cranach i'm gary
vaynerchuk's brand director
andy k get up here right here i got you
i see you andy's live streaming and he's
struggling let's give it up for andy k
i think like the hardest change for a
lot of people is actually just like a
mindset change you know so many people
don't want to
post a lot of content they just always
default into no
so many people think that tick tock
doesn't matter that it's still for young
kids
you know and like i don't think of the
change there being like oh you're gonna
go from not posting on tick tock to
posting on tick tock i think the change
that gary really is trying to empower
in millions of people and on his team
and in the organization
and in his content is the change of
saying yes
while everybody's spending 80 hours
trying to figure out the plan
of how to get on the six things you're
just doing
staying active right just say yes
everybody's saying no everybody's saying
no to [ __ ] because they think they're
being thoughtful or they're smart like
you know many people are saying no that
aren't even fancy enough to say yes yet
so i just say yes man a lot
the change of saying yes to
opportunities the change of
saying yes to what happens when you
publish and you start learning new
muscles
and i that's really what i challenge
myself off of when i listen to gary's
content
about changing is not drawing lines in
the sand for whatever the case may be
to being open to the other side of the
equation and feeling what that looks
like
everybody's so crippled by decisions but
you never know how the other thing
worked out let me give you an example
let's say you don't go to college and
you start this business and you were 100
right
and it's huge and you're doing so great
but because you did that you had to fly
to america
for a big meeting and your plane crashed
and you died
that would be a bad idea yeah or
you think you're gonna go to college
because it's a good experience and
you'll meet people you can meet people
in a business
you're not gonna know you know i think
people are crippled by change because
they feel like they make a decision and
that's it for the rest of their life but
you can decide tomorrow to be an actor
and the next day decide you want to be a
rapper and another day decide you want
to be a tick tocker
i think all are cool and interesting
ideas as long as you're being honest
with yourself and you're willing to put
in the work on the changes that you say
you're going to make happen
most people fear changing their mind
because they're worried about what
people will
judge them for when just a year ago they
said i'm gonna be
a fitness coach and then nine months
later they're selling pizzas and
everyone's like oh you're full of [ __ ]
and and it's not about being full of
[ __ ] it's you [ __ ] changed your mind
gary often makes decisions predicated on
his morals and values
so let's see how that translates to his
business life one thing gary i noticed
he's not afraid to walk away from
something
that challenges his values like if
somebody is going to ask them to do
something like he's not afraid to change
his mind
if it challenges his values i spend no
time
convincing people to believe in what i
believe in
so for me in my job as new business
development hat
there might be a client that might be a
great like opportunity
but if it doesn't if it if if it's
taking us down to path to do something
that's not
something we would do but what they want
he it's no brainer for him to walk away
from that
i like to say yes to everything but
they're absolutely moral
or concerns there's entire business
concepts that i'm just uncomfortable
with i think everybody should walk away
from certain business
based on their moral compass and
opportunity costs
but what i think he really understands
is that when you change your mind
that means that you're willing to hear
somebody and
gary for being somebody who is one of
the loudest
speakers i know and obviously produces
so much content to get his own message
out
is secretly the best listener and i
think a lot of people don't give him
credit for that i'm a full-time listener
everybody thinks i talk all the time all
i'm doing is listening the biggest
reason i talk so much is to get
reactions from you
whether one-on-one you in an audience
like this or the whole [ __ ] world
when i do content
i talk so much strategically to get
reactions so i can listen
so i can readjust and it's not just it's
not just hearing
it's listening which is a major
difference that where
you'll see people we all know people
like this that you're in a meeting and
somebody's just
they're hearing what you have to say but
they're just waiting until they have the
opportunity to talk next where
with gary it's listening absorbing
connecting dots figuring things out and
then
bringing his point which you always you
don't always get with
when you're uh watching his blog or
he'll say it so i'll say it on
askgaryvee when he's got
uh guests and sometimes he's talking
over him and stuff so someone would tell
me about that
but i have to ask you this in question
i'm sorry to interrupt you let me
interrupt i apologize
it's the name of the show thank you very
much
and not something that you would think
from watching him but knowing him
personally and being in meetings with
him and getting to know him so well he
is he's an incredible list
and it's something that i really admire
about everybody has a story
in chapter two let's take this back to
gary's best friend
brandon literally i'm doing what i did
when i was 16 years old with this guy my
best friend brandon
and mike we're literally doing a show
you having fun
like in an in in an uncomfortable
like can i muster up the courage to quit
everything i'm doing and only be a
baseball card dealer
like that much fun my name is brandon
werkey
um i met gary on my first day of high
school
in 1990 we developed a pretty quick
friendship
currently i'm running the operations at
wine library
and um doing a lot of the buying and
sales
as well as just you know day-to-day
operations kind of stuff that gary was
doing here
uh before he moved on to vaynermedia
gary and i you know our friendship
really was built on baseball cards it
was built on the fact that we both
we both loved to we both loved to
to buy and sell that was number one um
and we both loved baseball cards so it
was like the perfect you know the
perfect combo and so
for years that's you know that's all
that we did and it was it was a real
passion we had a great time their
memories that you know
are irreplaceable and and just just
unbelievable times
at 11 and 12 i was already going to
malls and hotels and selling baseball
cards at shows when i was 11 and 12
i was making a thousand dollars a
weekend selling baseball cards
how i had no money my parents had no
money what did i do
when it snowed i went to people's houses
rang their doorbell and asked them to
give me a dollar to five dollars to
shovel their
yard and they said yes and then i worked
for 30 minutes shoveled somebody's yard
got five bucks
or in the summer i got lemonade i set up
i did a lemonade stand like i did things
i didn't have
the internet but there came a point you
know towards the end of our our high
school days you know really our junior
i guess the end of our junior year
beginning of senior year where
the whole baseball card market was just
drowning and it just wasn't
wasn't very popular and slowly but
surely during the card shows we would do
there would be some dealers that would
set up
and they'd have half a table of cards
and then half a table of comics and toys
so there was definitely a shift in the
market
and gary saw it and you know
despite his real love for baseball cards
um
he was he was very ready to pivot to
wherever the market was going and at
that point the market was going to toys
and so you know i remember the very last
card show i ever did
i was already kind of burnt out i was
already kind of done
um i just i was spending a lot of money
not getting any in return
the card the value was worthless it
seemed and
we did this last show which was in
hillsborough
uh hillsboro new jersey and i went to
the show
and i walked in and gary was there and
his entire table
was full of toys no cards at all just
all toys
i didn't tell brandon that i had this
strategy he's setting up his cards
i started opening up these big boxes and
started putting out wizard of oz
and catwoman toys right
and i remember walking up and i looked
at him and i said what what is what is
this
and i was kind of upset because deep
down i knew
that was it it was over like the
baseball cards between us were done
the whole industry was dying and he goes
he goes we're gonna sell a ton of toys
today
and i said not me i i left i just i was
not
i couldn't do it i know this is the
future
bobby i literally was like nerd culture
i mean i nailed that
like in hindsight i [ __ ] nailed them
as a seven nobody thought about
marvel movies and star wars i [ __ ]
nailed it i just i couldn't i couldn't
change my mind
in that moment but gary sure did
and uh and the rest is history they went
on and he did toys which is where the
market was for
for quite a while only now with the last
three years that you guys will know
to come full circle back into cards
where now
it seems cards are the hottest thing
going i mean it's just it's unbelievable
so
that was from cards all in on cards
then all in on toys and then all back in
on cards
i believe we're on the we're in the
second quarter of four quarters
of the sports card industry exploding
again in culture
and i think there's a ton of money and a
lot of fun to be made
for a lot of entrepreneurs kids
especially sneaker kids
who can't get enough inventory of hard
to get sneakers but if they want to go
buy 5 000 giannis rookies
or 400 darko rookies they can
and so i'm excited because it's
something i love
something i understand but i'm in a new
era in my life
it's not about the million dollars that
i'll make in flipping cards in the next
three years and i will
it's about it's about you know the
tens of thousands of kids that i'm gonna
impact
who are gonna make a hundred thousand
bucks in profit
in the next two years instead of raising
a million dollars
and losing it and that i'm excited about
i'm excited about pushing
people and teaching them how to make
money instead of raising money
and raising money has become the sport
of entrepreneurship in this era
not making it and it's something that
i'm trying to bring conversation to
so are you guys flipping cards too
throughout his career
gary often made pivots but then he
started vaynermedia
which then led him to go all in on his
personal brand in 2014.
my name is stefan i've been at
vaynermedia since
november 2014 i believe
and uh during that time i
i've started out on gary's team working
on team gary with drock when it was just
meeting him pumping out videos and i've
since then transitioned to vaynertalent
which is basically what i was doing for
gary what the team is doing for gary we
do
for uh other people who want to build
their personal brand by the way staphon
let's show staphon
uh trying to get some ladies out of this
uh why not this is so ridiculous
this this is so ridiculous get down here
staphon i want you to work with me
i mean i think one of the things that
you learned early on
being on gary's team is to not be
comfortable doing the same thing all the
time
that like you know starting out it was
askgaryvee then it would move to
dailyvee then it was like we just want a
bunch of clips just to put out clips and
then it was just like
just kind of always having to think
about what was next
i mean the good thing with gary is that
his mind was always there so you were
just kind of like okay cool
and you try to get ahead of it to try to
present him with stuff but you learned
pretty early on that like
there's always going to be what's next
which kind of made you
comfortable with um just kind of always
being on your toes always being ready to
adapt and do something new and to not
get stagnant and not get comfortable
doing the day-to-day stuff like it's so
obvious to me what's gonna happen with
dailyvee and snapchat
like our execution these next 12 months
is gonna be it's gonna be so
[ __ ] crazy you know i thought that
dailyvee was just gonna be like a name
not like we're gonna do it it's gonna be
like a dailyvee just kind of like more
frequent
like not necessarily a dailyvee so when
it was happening
so you know drock was pretty much
responsible for shooting it all
and then turning it around and then so
you know that responsibility
kind of shifted to me too it's kind of
you know drock was shooting and i would
edit them
um and it was in the beginning it's like
oh like this is like a real thing
this is not this ain't no joke this
doesn't this isn't just something you do
in a
you know a couple hours because these
dailyvee's weren't
two and three minutes long this uh
this daily vlog has been such a big deal
why you hear that
just just put that part there yeah it
was definitely like a transition i'm
just like oh like it was a little
jarring at first but then just like
anything else you figure out the cadence
you figure out how to make it work and
then
you get into that flow and then you just
get it done until he changes up the
format again and then you're like doing
it all over again but it's just like you
kind of get comfortable
with the change you know being
comfortable with change
is not always easy let's take it over to
tyler babin and hear why he made the
change to leave vaynermedia
my name is tyler babin i worked on team
gary for about
three and a half years total started in
uh
may of 2016 was a big editor for just
instagram and facebook clips and then
drock and i ended up alternating days
and we were both traveling
all over the place filming dailyvee and
then i left that position about a year
ago to
kind of just go out and do my own thing
i'm gonna miss you bro i'm gonna see you
man
a lot super surreal
i'm really happy though for you man i
appreciate it i really feel good about
it yeah
it feels like like the right move right
now yeah i think that's the right
sentence the right move right now
there was a video that i made at one
point um
it's called 99 happy and gary had
done a whole speech where he said he was
99 happy in his life and one percent
being unhappy made him literally change
everything
on my 30th birthday i was driving from
new york to new jersey to the store
and realized i was only 99 happy
that one percent made me change my
entire life
if you're not 100 pumped
every second if you actually are happy
it's the weekend
or are pumped to go on vacation your
[ __ ] is broken
and i felt myself creeping way above one
percent of my life being unhappy
and i said all right cool it's just like
it's time to to leave and do something
else and i knew that i had built up
enough equity and enough relationships
that
i wasn't no matter what happened like i
didn't think i would ever leave on bad
terms and i
don't think i'm on bad terms with anyone
in that building and so for me
being able to like step away and just
say like you know what i need to like
feed my soul for a while and do the
things that are
on my mind is really important and so i
think that there's never
a wrong thing with realizing once you
have the thing you wanted so badly
that you can change your mind and go a
different route like anything
nothing's permanent you can always go
backwards and you can
like life is not a linear thing you can
move up and down and like go different
directions and so just being willing to
embrace
that i think is where you will find like
actual true happiness
i always play this out let's say when
you go to heaven
they can show you what would have
happened because that's the only way
you'd ever see it
let's just say what people don't
understand is oh basha you made the
wrong call
you should have went to grad school
instead of that opportunity or this
company instead of that company
but you'll never believe it if you would
have went there you would have excel
you should have went to vaynermedia not
there but it's terrible
you actually went to vayner and it was
perfect and you rose like a phoenix
and you were the head of all sound and
everything went great but then you had
to go to virginia on business
and you got hit by a car and you died at
31. so
to like look at two ideas and think you
can practically make a good decision
is laughable literally flip a coin just
pick the one that feels better right
that second
and make it about you because usually
what kids struggle with is the decision
they want to do
versus the decision that they think
they're supposed to do based on the
other voices
do you remember india from the
askgaryvee show she's going to talk
about her relationship with gary
so let's see her side of the story india
i think it's time to get into the sh
show let's
get into the show
wait a minute how do we not talk about
this because we we talked about in real
life
you know vayner nation look at this i
mean
india i mean i you know talk about
kissing up to the boss stunwin
my name is india i worked at vaynermedia
from 2012
until august very recently august 2019.
i started as a community manager in 2012
and worked my way through a bunch of
different roles the company but
got to work with gary for a few years as
his producer and copywriter
and then just before i left the company
i was working on vaynertalent as a
creative producer
one big thing that's very personal to me
that i changed about myself working for
gary was
my confidence just in the workplace and
being able to
sit in a room as a woman working with a
lot of men
and state my opinion and stated very
strongly and be confident
in my own abilities um i think that's
something i really struggled with you
know
vayner was my first professional job out
of college so i learned a lot working
there and i learned a lot of really
important skills but that was one that i
didn't really totally develop till i was
working directly for gary he rock zoom
in
to my ear right you know the ear
is the key in this scenario because the
truth is the way to push somebody above
their limits
is to actually have individual
conversations with them
about what is their holy you know grail
right like
what do they want to accomplish like
india and i i like i have a good feel of
some of india's long-term career
ambitions and like that gives me
first of all her knowing that we've even
had that conversation in itself
gives her a little bit more confidence
to work harder
because she's trying to get what she
wants out of it
professionally and knowing that i'm the
person that could most likely make that
happen at least in the context of this
world
that just even having the conversation
puts her in a better spot
one of the meetings i had with gary one
of the first times i talked to him
one-on-one i was like you know i didn't
study marketing in school i studied
painting and he was like i didn't study
marketing in school either you know
um and i think he really helped me
change my mindset about that and realize
that it doesn't really matter you know
what you did before and you just have to
focus on what you do want to do right
now and move ahead with that
there's nothing you should do yeah you
need to focus on what you want to do
yeah yeah just cause somebody else says
it's good you know what i mean yeah
what you should do is look yourself in
the mirror and say what
what do i think i'm decent at and what
do i like and do one of those and if
and if you're lucky enough that what
you're good at you like then it's really
[ __ ] the moon
if you shoot for the moon you'll land
among the stars so here's alex
gary's executive assistant for the last
two and a half years
she's going to share her perspective on
adapting to the current task at hand
vaynernation alex is here alex alexar
alex
i'm alex raffington uh i started vayner
august of 2016.
i started working for the office team at
the front desk
i had a friend that actually worked at
vayner and i kind of wanted to get into
the agency side and
i used to work at a bakery previously
and i kind of like
fall into that rut of just working
somewhere for so long and not actually
like kind of going
for the job you actually want and uh he
was like this is
might be like a good first step for you
so i started on the office team i worked
there for about almost a year and a half
and then uh talked to tyler
uh he was assistant at the time and he
definitely needed some help
and then i moved up on team gary moved
into the spot of being gary's assistant
as well
so i've been working that for uh two and
a half years
i adore alex right i'm looking right at
her
in the last week or two there's things
that i've told her that i want
done better and and i hope she would
tell you that
i'm not yelling i'm like trying to
deliver with honey like
right even when you agree when i come
with you with something i'm almost being
a little passive
being an admin comes with structure in
in process and that is poor that's a
part of like being
an admin but just know that
if you have to pivot that's okay or if
the kind of if the the structure that
you created for yourself is too rigid
then just just back away a little bit
and you know just know that
it's okay if something doesn't work
anymore and you have to pivot it's not
that you're not a good admin or you're
not working to your full potential
it's just that things just change the
game is changing
quickly and often and if you're not
adjusting
you're going to lose the you know the 85
bears one on a system that doesn't work
in today's nfl
so you just gotta keep evolving and if
you don't you lose
and that's the evolution of my game so
advice that i gave in jab jab jab right
hook
would have looked differently today
about twitter because between the time i
wrote it
and this minute the game has changed so
just know that it's okay to change it's
okay to kind of move things around but
also ask questions
that's the best thing for you to do is
ask questions
you know so then you can make the best
decision going for it we changed our
mind
seven times a month i constantly
[ __ ] on my own self once a week like i
emphatically on monday say it's all
about this
and literally next tuesday go if we ever
do that again we're fi i mean
this is real life this is the truth you
know we always joke like
the admins a lot of times he'll come up
you know we'll get on the phone
and he'll be like new rule new rule new
rule new rule i think it's like a big
kind of thing
can you text tyler and say new rule i'm
being dead serious
new rule here's literally how we're
gonna do it new rule
no more and then three days later you
know
something comes up that proves that it
wasn't that smart yeah we don't need
that new rule anymore and most people
are like you know it gets
there's some fatigue to it but only if
you
put so much weight into like
the rigidness of systems
and processes i always say that process
and systems are there to take thought
out of things and the second i get too
habitually ingrained into process
how you take notes how you do your to-do
list how you organize your email inbox
like there's efficiency to it but at the
same time once you
rely on the process over the thought
you just become you know attached to the
process
it takes a lot of thinking out of the
situation creativity out of the
situation
you better keep your subjectiveness and
your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do
you better [ __ ] move so i'm always
once i get too close to just like
relying on the process i try and break
it and change it up
if you're relying on the process and
having a tough time accepting the change
mentality
what you will discover is that most
systems will get broken
as well as other projects along the way
let's hear one of the most recent
stories about how we went all in on a
project
i'll laugh and think about the moment
that we pitched him on
interrupted by garyvee as a new show in
format and we spent a lot of time on
thoughtful designs and positioning on
that new show
and we did one episode and he decided he
didn't want to do anymore
i'm changing the name of interrupted by
yeah because i just
like reading the comments i just don't i
think it triples down on
something i don't want it to so the
reality is is that show is now cancelled
um i think that's just a great example
of he could have continued to do it
because
we put this emphasis on it but he
intuitively felt like it wasn't the
right thing to do for his brand so
he stopped it and i think our team does
a great job on being
unemotional about those changes and
continuing to learn and
evolve unemotional decision making
is what has allowed me the great luxury
of standing at this table
i it's not a table [ __ ]
i'm comfortable in chaos that's my happy
place
uh i was people like how don't you drop
balls i'm like i drop a shitload of
balls
except i'm some people like to have two
balls in the air and not drop them
i like to have 73 and drop 13. i like
the net of that my dad used to get so
pissed when i was
building wine library he would always be
like [ __ ] he's like he would say like
three months ago you said ricky was
gonna be the best employee i'm like i
changed my mind he [ __ ] fire him
or or he's like you said sparkling wine
was important now you just eliminated it
from the key spot i'm like
i changed my mind like my ability to
only be comfortable
in massive chaos has been my biggest
asset as an entrepreneur
i was as about as far as you could be
down the process of moving to london
with eric folweiler to help open our
office there
and we were in the office i think it was
like about a month away
to move and that's a pretty big move i
was 25 at the time 24 25
was getting ready to move over to london
with a team of five
and gary just calls me into the office
and asks if i want to be his assistant
and it was like kind of like well aren't
i
doing this and he's like well
it doesn't have any impact like meaning
yes but
this is something new and new
information and new situation and new
data
and the the not
um not necessarily not taking into
account but not letting just because
that is the case
affect that aspect uh
of taking that role was the first
like real eye-opening thing and you
don't feel you don't think twice or feel
bad about it something like that because
when i make decisions i'm making them at
that moment and things
change if i emailed my direct reports my
leaders tomorrow and said
we're now selling actual honey like we
are no longer an agency we now produce
honey i just bought a honey farm and
and you know paso robles and and we now
sell honey
and i just think 80 percent of them be
like okay like what what am i doing like
yes yes comma so when you build culture
and you build trust you can go fast and
so
when you put a plan in place or if
you're a leader and you say we're going
to do this
and everyone says cool i'm ready to go
and then you realize that that isn't the
right thing
most people are probably scared that
people are going to judge them as a
flip-flopping leader
if they believe that that then is the
right thing be
binary about your decisions let me tell
you what i mean by that
don't overthink jumping into your first
job
and then quit it the next day if it
doesn't feel right it's not
a end-all be-all if the first one's not
right
that doesn't mean you can't be
thoughtful along the way
right it doesn't mean that you can make
a decision you're doing it and then a
couple weeks in even though three weeks
earlier it seems so right you're like
wait a minute this feels like a waste of
time
and then even if you declare to your
whole world that you're doing this
people fear changing their mind out of
judgment
and then you start to go down a path
that just gets too caught up
where you're too far away from being
able to say
actually no this is the right thing i've
been presented with new information
new data and i'm making this decision
and
you know communication goes into a lot
of that but there's this kind of
that's happening right now like are we
supposed to do what's best for us
first or best for other people even if
it's at the detriment
of our own self though it seems like the
ability to change your mind is instilled
at birth
this is something you need to work on
let's hear from gary's brother aj on his
mindset at an early age
i've actually really shifted i think
that i
naturally growing up was a bit more
focused and put a lot more energy
and put a lot more stock into your
original thought and opinion
and i thought that if you changed your
mind then it just validated that your
original opinion was wrong
and so because gary is so willing and
able to change his opinion in mind
i think there was you know gary and i
really don't have a lot of friction
aj and i because of our age difference
have almost
a brother father kind of thing going on
that's very
kind of unique and special and we've
been we've we've met so many people that
are
11 or 12 or 9 or 10 years apart and
don't have
what we have you know it's tough i mean
i was out of the house
when he was seven right and so it's just
a very
unique thing that we have a very very
very special bond
we nearly never fight and have ever
fought over business
if we ever fight it's over the silliest
[ __ ] it's stuff like board games and
pickup basketball right
i once punched my brother aj on a
basketball court
and i've never really said it because i
don't want to admit it actually happened
but when there was friction in the early
days was probably centered a little bit
around
the changing your mind concept and i
think what i struggled with the most
was how um constant it was
and how effortless it was right it kind
of almost
i think what i struggled with was it
almost invalidated the original thought
and made it really tough for me to
accept and receive
initial thoughts from gary he would say
something like well you're just gonna
change your damn mind tomorrow
like why do i why should i even receive
this why should i take this seriously
but i think as i got more exposure and
more experience to business and
and life than people um i grew to
appreciate it a lot more and i felt like
i needed a shift and it wasn't
necessarily a conscious effort i didn't
say i need to be able to change my mind
more i need to be able to change my mind
more
i think it just came from um experience
and
i think it speaks a little bit to the
idea of us starting businesses and
things like that
and whether it's starting a business or
starting an initiative within a company
i think that um ultimately
if you fail or if something is
inaccurate it's okay as long as you
adjust and as long as you adjust towards
the positive
this has been historic like factories
factories had to adjust to machines
farmers had to adjust the tractors you
know
retail stores had to adjust to registers
that were computers
versus cash this is not complicated
this is historic here's the punch line
the market is the market
what is the 54 year old gonna do adjust
or lose something gary likes to say
before giving advice is
i never think i'm right because gary
knows he's just stating one man's
opinion
in this next chapter we're going to dive
into different perspectives on the topic
tell me how to save my life tell me i'm
going to tell you right now
i'm going to tell you right now my god
say what's up with my partner ryan how
you doing
you know ego is usually the driving
force behind the
deep desire to be right right i have to
be right
and they say like be selective in your
battles
but sometimes peace is better than being
right so if you have the
ability to firmly believe something and
recognize when you're wrong
and admit it and implement change
accordingly
it means you have macro strength not
micro
stubbornness so to say people overthink
it
yeah and they have ego that i'm the only
one that does it best and then nobody's
ever good enough
go within humility tell them the truth
gotcha and then if they don't deliver on
it fire i've watched so many people that
are great at their craft
never build a business because of ego
that they like
feeling that they're better at this
thing than anybody than actually scaling
a business
okay you know it's what i did
essentially like i was in finance i
worked for goldman sachs for seven years
and then pivoted to be in media but
women's
lifestyle media as a young male um
and i was laughed at you know people
definitely laugh behind my back being
like what is this guy
doing um but i knew that i i just knew
that i would not be
happy being in the corporate america
flywheel
where it's not solely based on merit
and i wanted to be part of something
that what i put into it
was hopefully what i got out of it or at
least i sealed my own
fate winning is happy not making more
money
because you focused only on the tech
company what are you trying to
accomplish and by the way
it's okay if that [ __ ] changes
you know 27 you might need money or
a boyfriend or a girlfriend at 34 you
might want to have more like
white work-life balance because you have
a child now at 41 you might need more
money because you wasted your money
after you had a good like
it's okay for it to change daily for me
when moving from finance to media
i convinced myself whether it was true
or not
that if i failed that i can easily
go back to finance even if i took one
step back
i can go back to finance get a job get a
salary um
so i think that you need to think worst
case scenario
and are you okay financially are you
okay with the lifestyle you might have
to lead
if you do fail entirely do you have a
family
do you have kids are you single are you
know do you have dependents
that you need to make a minimum amount
of money in order to support those
people
because that might be a driving force
behind taking a certain risk so
i don't think you should i don't think
i'm not saying that
you should do that create fear in your
mind but you need to understand what
your
your downside is what your worst case
scenario is and that will help you give
you comfort
because if you can convince yourself
that you're okay with that downside
you're gonna go all in and you're not
gonna look back
gary likes to talk about how he missed
out on investing in uber during the
angel round
what we haven't heard is aj's side of
the story so let's take a look
you know i guess this is a fun example
you know gary and i had the opportunity
to invest in the seed round in uber uh
gary talks about it all the time
my most devastating business decisions
have been predicated at the moments when
i bought my two homes
i passed i've never said this this
clearly i passed on uber because i
bought an apartment
if i just stayed in the apartment i was
in for one more year
i would have 400 million that i don't
have right now
that's about as basic as i can say it
and then we had they reapproached us for
the series b and they're like come on
guys because these are personal friends
they're like come on guys like i know
you missed out on the seed
but it's been a little while we have
really good traction we'd love to have
you for the ride right
and i think somebody that maybe would be
too stuck in the mud would uh
would cut their nose to spite their face
right
and not invest but you know gary and i
say you know what let's keep our nose
intact let's bite the bullet
let's forget about our regret let's move
forward we don't regret twice
it's you know better late than never and
so we ended up investing in uber in the
series b and did really well because of
it
could have done better at the seed but
that's life you take your losses along
the way
the single biggest reason boehner x got
to where it got to
um beyond gary's brand equity and his
salesmanship and his
and his public brand is our
disproportionate willingness to
communicate top down right
and so you know spending the time and
energy to talk to your
executive team as well as your entry
level employee that just started two
weeks ago
it's about people when you go from one
to five locations it's about people
and i think just having an authentic
line of communication
and an open door policy that people
actually believe to be true
um is massively important when shifting
through um
change being the bigger person is not
always the easiest thing to do
let's hear from mark yudkin on how gary
shaped his perspective on this
i'm mark yudkin i'm now chief operating
officer and general counsel
of all of vayner x i've known gary for
about 13 to 14 years now
i did a lot of his legal work as outside
counsel
before vayner media was formed i did
his investment work in uber and tumblr
and twitter and facebook and all that
stuff so i was a lawyer for those deals
um so i've gotten pretty good insight
into gary for
the last 13 or 14 years and it's been a
fun ride
i tend to be i tend to think i'm usually
right because i usually am
but uh it's been harder for me to
sometimes
bite my lip and kind of be the bigger
man and walk away even though i know
it's the right thing to do
um and i think he has taught me
that sometimes there's greater benefit
to
even though you might be right to just
kind of walk away and be the bigger man
in a situation because the benefits
derived
later on will far exceed the
advantages now of saying hey i told you
so or hey i'm right now in this
particular case
so it's not a particular instance but i
definitely think it's a particular
character trait that i it was tough for
me at first
um but to realize that in the end it's
always better to be the bigger person
it's one of the things that i'm spending
a lot of time on one that a lot of
people aren't capable of executing
which is how much better life is when
you're the bigger man and woman in every
situation
no matter if you're right or wrong no
matter what it is
are you capable of swallowing your pride
and having the humility
to uh to say you're sorry even when
maybe it wasn't yours to say you're
sorry
leadership and uh and happiness
really really really comes at the uh
at the ability to uh
to focus on one move which is can you be
the bigger person
for example being a good number two
three four at vaynermedia is pretty
simple like i'm going to care if you're
capable of being the bigger person
empathy a leader that leads
positive energy like you're not like you
can sell them
trillion dollars in my company like if
you're a dick face you're going to lose
changing your mind shows growth changing
your mind
shows vulnerability and vulnerability is
one of the strongest things that
you can have these days i mean everybody
is so guarded and so defensive
and you know i think right now
especially we're seeing a huge moment
where a lot of people
are being asked to change their mind and
you could say that it's you know
one political extremist and you're
trying to get him all the way to the
other extreme but it's not you know it's
like people within even a small faction
just asking for a little mind chip
and i think that you know that shows
yeah tremendous growth
and an ability to really become
malleable and
allow yourself to be shaped by
experiences because we are shaped by our
experiences the person
you are today is shaped by what you
experienced before so why shouldn't you
change your life is not static your life
is never going to be the same thing over
and over so
to expect yourself never to change your
mind and never change at all is
completely unrealistic anyway gary
believes that speed is one of the most
important things an entrepreneur needs
to be comfortable with claude silver
vaynermedia's chief heart officer talks
about how speed is crucial to
vaynermedia's success
as of this announcement the next most
important role in this company
underneath me
and so it's a big one so as of today
starting on monday
we now have a chief heart officer
and that chief heart officer is uh
actually here so i think we should grab
our chief
heart officer
you know coming from the larger
advertising agencies that i was at for
years and what seemed like centuries
things go
slowly change takes a very long time
and there are a lot of layers and levels
and a lot of t's to cross and eyes to
dot
and one of the things that was very
apparent to me
year one at vayner is that we go fast
here
we go faster than fast i mean i believe
that we actually
create speed speed is the game
and if you can't execute fast you can't
win because by the time you execute on
your promise
the world [ __ ] moved on you so i
really had to learn
how to jog and be very comfortable in a
jog
and then know when i needed to sprint
and you know now i'm so used to it that
i actually expect other people to be
able to
sprint just like i'm sprinting and i
have to realize and i'm sure
gary has to realize this every day like
not everyone is going to be where you
are
all the time which lends itself to
patience
i know i'm on to something so
fundamentally different
and i know that i can inspire people to
do it because it's going to have the
empire part too
see that's what people don't get the
reason i'm going to win
is because i've got both the honey part
means that you want to go change the
world the empire part means
you'll do it at all costs i'm neither so
really being okay with where people are
being patient enough feeding and
nurturing them enough
encouraging them you know leading by
example so that they get it
because when someone finally gets that
speed of how we do it at vayner like
they get
high it's an amazing feeling like we
spend so much time
overthinking instead of doing do it then
know
then decide speed it's all speed
like you got to go fast that's how you
get [ __ ] done that's how you figure
stuff out
speed without control is reckless
his speed has control meaning
it's either been a honed process as he
he's done it a hundred times before so
therefore he
can right let's say he's evaluating a
company to invest it was invested in
hundreds
right so he could tell in 15 minutes if
it's the right company or not it looks
like an impulsive investment it's not an
impulsive investment he's got
he honed it over years i find it super
fascinating that people think
fast decisions can be reckless because
they themselves
tend to question their decisions
and they're imposing their insecurity as
judgment on others who have pattern
recognition experience
conviction and confidence in decisions
they make i make very fast decisions
when i have all the data
and i have full confidence in my
decision i make very slow decisions
when i don't have the data or i haven't
figured it out yet
demonizing fast decision making as
reckless
is laughable the judge of that tends to
be the insecure
some decisions don't take a lot of
strategy just a gut feeling
in this chapter we're going to see how
entrepreneurs can be more conscious
about using intuition and gut decisions
so there's something that gary used to
say a lot
um that that the magic is in the gray
the world is grey i play in the great
because the world is great and i think
that really just comes from the spirit
of
always being ready to pivot and whether
that's because the marketplace is
telling you to pivot
or it's culture telling you to pivot or
it's gary telling me directly that i
need to pivot or me
telling him that i think we need to
pivot on something um
you know gives that both core strength
but then the flexibility to just
roll with the punches um get stuff done
and really harness the power of your
gut as opposed to you know sitting and
waiting
for things to change it's it's very much
the um
you know be the change because you're
smart and capable
everybody's so absolute you know
world is gray i think the interesting
thing about gary
and all good leaders is just clear
communication so when gary
really feels strongly about something
when he is like
trust me six months ago we are going to
double down on tick
tock and here are the reasons why
you you trust and you and you definitely
fall into line
um and there are other times that he's
like i
i have you know reading tea leaves and
whatnot or like
reading the marketplace or you know
conversations like i'm feeling something
now tell me how that will work in this
place
he's also open to that and then the
third
he'll he'll definitely be in a
conversation and he'll say like
actually gary we're seeing like the
opposite happen
and sometimes he's like i don't care
screw it we'll write our own feature
and sometimes he's like oh super
interesting okay don't disregard what i
just said
but if you're set in your ways and
you're not open to
others ideas or other thoughts or others
opinions and
immediately that they say something and
it's oh
your opinion's different than mine
you're wrong um i think that is a
terrible way to be and i and i feel i've
never
i've never been that way and and
obviously i
you mature and get better and gary was a
major part of that where
you see him he has that um mentality
where
everybody's opinion is allowed um there
are no bad ideas there may be bad ideas
but i still want to hear your bad ideas
um so i think it's being open to
changing your mind on all things
um that really matters and not just kind
of
changing your mind or being set in your
ways i i think the openness to things
is what really matters what people when
people hear in the ad world two to four
thousand piece of content
they think it's schizophrenic they think
it's throwing it up against the wall
they think it's not quality there's a
lot of
negative connotation on it in the
creative space which is too bad because
i actually think the thesis that i'm
talking about
is going to be the golden era of
creativity i'm in the
i'm in the discipline that's very
disciplined right there's a lot of
process there's a lot of ways of working
there's a lot of you know methodologies
to the way we approach things but i
think despite that i've always gone with
what makes the most sense you know
intuitively like what do you feel in
your heart
and and what makes sense to to you as a
professional to you as a human being
to you as a consumer and i think that
that's one of the reasons gary and i
bonded you know because
if for as much um discipline as we bring
to it
a lot of what we do this is marketing
it's common sense
it's common sense and and with that
common sense comes human intuition
and you have to lean into that and i
think that i've been most successful
when i've been able to do that
you know but um you have to go with the
things that kind of feel right and that
really resonate with you
as an individual you know um because i
think that that's where the truth kind
of lies
and here's the good news we're going
through this at vayner right now i'm
looking at james and mark like we had
this big meeting and i was like
like in the beginning in the end i was
like look i'm changing the direction of
our creative output and our strategic
and creative output
and it's super okay if you don't agree
with me because i know it's fairly rogue
and so like come and see me and i'll get
you a job doing what you want to do
for more money somewhere else this
doesn't have to be bad back to person
i don't want bad i just don't want to go
to business
i'm definitely i'm in charge of running
the business so i'm going to change the
direction and
you know you're a hockey player i just
and we've been playing hockey and now
i'm saying we're playing basketball not
everybody's gonna transfer that skill
and that's okay and i think that's what
you do you can read about push-ups all
day
but until you start doing them you won't
improve
in this chapter we'll hear how doing
always beats thinking
i joke about the dms that i get that say
andy how do i start a podcast
and i joke because the answer is really
easy it's you start
you know and i think i've really started
to analyze my own actions and my own
thoughts and ideas um and as i've
consumed gary's content and i watch
gary's content
there's just such a big difference
between doing and thinking and
pontificating
you know i think so many people enjoy
the comfort of
thinking and strategizing and reading
and plan planning and ideating
versus just jumping in and doing it
enough listening start doing [ __ ]
don't be scared and if you're scared
find somebody who's not scared make them
your partner
like it's action it's going it's doing i
think there's lots of people that want
to make changes in their lives
and they think they're doing it by
planning out how they're going to have a
30-day diet and that they're
going to go keto and they're going to
have no alcohol
and how awesome it's going to be and how
much weight they're going to lose
versus just immediately saying no i'm
not going to eat that pasta because
now i'm on a keto diet
um it's just implementing it right then
and there
doing it starting it pressing the button
versus planning
plotting strategizing [ __ ] you're gonna
go do it do [ __ ]
learn put in the work i think the
hardest thing
to do is make decisions that's why
people don't change their mind
in this indecisiveness is like
so brutal and that that i think getting
past
indecisiveness is the hardest thing and
that's changing your mind because a lot
of decisions
as you grow like growth is changing your
mind
so like when you get when you're
presented with new data or new
experiences or you've gone through
something and now you know more
and you have to make a decision to
change most people just don't make the
decision
they're not actively deciding to not
change they're just simply not deciding
to change
you know i always hear people like
should we do this should we do that
they're crippled by their indecisiveness
and their worries about total reaction
it's not what you do it's how you follow
up on that mistake
it's not how you spill the milk it's how
you clean it up that's really what's
important in business
normalizing changing your mind is
something that
when you're presented with new
information you should be really
comfortable doing so in a perfect
example is what's happening now with
black lives matter
and all the racial injustice like we
have new information
it's okay to change our minds it's okay
to say
i didn't know what i didn't know and now
that i do
i'm going to change my behaviors i'm
going to lean in more to
stepping up i'm going to do my part to
be more engaged like
it's it's we have to normalize changing
your mind is
a strength because we get new
information and we live
in a 24-hour real-time environment where
if you get new information and you don't
change your mind
then you're being you're a disservice to
yourself and to everyone around you
because
i always say like if i'm not learning
i'm not growing if i'm not growing i'm
dying so like
you know changing your mind and being
comfortable with changing your mind
means that you're growing because you're
taking in the new information that you
have been exposed to
and you're actually using it to do
something better i think the important
thing is and particularly now
in the face of a pandemic and in the
face of a world that continues to change
and acknowledge
things like you know racial injustice
and social injustice
we're realizing that we as leaders need
to be
listening and learning and pivoting all
the time
and where we'll fail frankly is when we
think we know the answer and that we
just keep blindly going down a path
without always checking ourselves and i
think
now more than ever um you know we're in
this very
we're in a tougher place now than we
were even at the beginning of covid
we need to be more sensitive we need to
learn we need to take action
but it's got to be the right action uh
and so to me the the whole idea of
changing your mind
um it sounds like it's a negative in our
society for some reason it sounds like
you're ambivalent
or that you're disingenuous or that
you're
um you're not committed or you're not
intelligent but it
actually is a strength and it's
something that i think if more leaders
could subscribe to celebrating that and
maybe there's a different way of even
framing up that narrative
um i think we'd be in a much better
place um you know it's really funny
i always talk about don't be in the
middle don't be half pregnant i pull
from opposite directions i have
you know a lot of what is interesting
about me is i see very very different
people associate with my message
people that genuinely don't agree on a
single thing politically or socially
because they're hearing different things
for me and i i bounce around
and i'm been thinking a lot about it you
know
parenting philosophy entrepreneurship
philosophy obviously political
philosophy like we are pulling further
and further apart from each other people
are pulling in such
opposite directions yet i i
i feel like there's so many merits and
so many different nuanced points of view
and i just think that we've become so
one-dimensional and so
absolute uh i think we have to start
talking more about
allowing people to change their mind i
think if we make changing
your mind something that is put on a
pedestal
instead of demonized you know i think
that would really help us gary doesn't
believe
in one
subjective opinion being the person
that can say that idea is the one that
should be executed
especially if it it has minimal
financial risk to it
it's like do them all and see what the
consumer thinks
what you know find right instead of
guess right
and our industry as a whole is much more
you know guess write versus find right
because
they'll say that it's schizophrenia or
they'll say that it's throwing things
against the wall until it sticks or
it's not on brand or whatever it may be
where it you know
we don't we don't necessarily believe in
that as much because
we think that the consumer should decide
what is quality
versus three people in a boardroom
deciding what is quality
based on you know what they their
opinion of
quality and i think a lot about that now
with my content
which is why am i so comfortable with
trying things i posted a video yesterday
that was upside down on instagram
i don't know how many of you saw it and
and
and maybe and then a couple days earlier
i made a video where i just said like
this post like
58 times in a row and i've been using
this hashtag
tag in the two posts that you know
always be testing
and it's really my way to give you a nod
of giving you permission
the like like like video did okay the
upside down video yesterday did not do
well
and that excites me and i'm excited to
spend more time over the next
you know year or two of trying things
completely left field
to hopefully inspire people to you know
what i'm so
unbelievably concerned about for
everybody in here who's creating content
whether on youtube or instagram or other
places
is you've become so obsessed with the
number associated with the post that
you're not actually even putting out
anymore what you want to put out
you're putting out what you know is
going to work i mean too many of you are
not doing things because you're worried
about how it's going to make you look
because you're late
so you're not starting which is always a
bad idea
right it's a huge thing that's happening
i think this you know i'm always
thinking about the sound bite that may
help you
i'm pumped right now because i have a
funny feeling two or three we're like
[ __ ] maybe i should
you know you're i get it i understand
brand i understand
[ __ ] i'm supposed to be this and i have
less than all these but if you don't
start you don't get
and by the way cream always rises to the
top
if you're so good right you'll be there
well guys you've made it this far thanks
for watching until the end
now we'll take it over to gary the thing
that baffles my mind
is that people don't realize that there
is no monday morning quarterbacking
in life you can talk on monday morning
and be upset what your quarterback did
sam darnold i need you this year but in
real life
when you decide to buy real estate
in the hamptons and it doesn't work out
or buy a five dollar sneaker
and become a flipper instead of a lawyer
you don't know how your life plays out
as a lawyer
so you're either an optimist or a
pessimistic person
the optimistic person goes and does flip
like it doesn't work out and they
realize
well i would have done the law thing i
would have made some more money but i
would have been so unhappy and i'm glad
because now i'm
this thing i'm a teacher in this high
school and i'm super happy
the pessimistic person does great in
flipping does a million a year and
decides they would have made 3 million a
year
as being a lawyer and that's the only
thing they value is money so they
[ __ ] lost
you decide you decide if you're winning
and losing before it even happens
so like can we just once and for all
make people
understand that they have no idea that
knowing what the right decision is at
the time you're making the decision
is humanly impossible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]